hello
this is baba from simply learn welcome
to this video on symmetric key
cryptography
as per our last video on what is
cryptography you must now have a basic
idea of the subject
and why it is so vital in today's
digital landscape
if you haven't checked out the original
video we highly suggest you to watch
that one before proceeding further
the link of which you will find below in
the description box let's have a look at
our plan for the session
we're going to take a small recap on
cryptography and understand the types of
cryptography
and our focus for the day within dive
into symmetrically cryptography and its
working
we learn about the terminology behind
private key cryptography
we learn the type of ciphers being used
today and the advantages of using
symmetric key cryptography
let's have a small recap before we move
ahead
cryptography is the science of
encryption and decryption of data
to prevent unauthorized access
encryption is the process of making the
plaintext unreadable
to any third party which generates the
ciphertext
decryption of process of reversing the
encrypted text
back to its original readable format
that has the plain text
as you can see in the image the plain
text in the example is the word study
the sender uses an encryption key to
convert the plain text into
text which will be unreadable to the
people who don't have the decryption key
the cipher text can be a combination of
random alphanumeric characters
it is then sent directly to the receiver
who then converts the cipher text back
to the plain text
that is the word study using a
decryption key
depending on the type of cryptography
being used the decryption
key can be the same key used for the
encryption or it can be completely
different
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric cryptography and asymmetric
key cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetric key cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted
with so many aspects of banking moving
on to the internet
having a reliable safety net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud
and boosts the security index of these
payment gateways in general
[Music]
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit
and dress on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted
with a fast and efficient algorithm so
that when the data needs to be recalled
by the respective service
there is the assurance of minor to no
delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we
get an all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity
exchanging the necessary encryption keys
required and generating a session
using those keys to ensure maximum
security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure http website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key
that they will use to convert the plain
text into ciphertext
and vice versa as you can see in the
image the key used for encryption is the
same key needed for decrypting the
message at the other end
the secret key shouldn't be sent along
with the cipher text to the receiver
because that would defeat the entire
purpose of using cryptography
key exchange can be done beforehand
using other algorithms like the
diffie-hellman key exchange protocol for
example
for example if paul wants to send a
simple message to jane
they need to have a single encryption
key that both of them must give secret
to prevent snooping on by malicious
actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message i am ready is
converted into cipher text using a
specific substitution cipher by paul
in that case jane must also be aware of
the substitution shift
to decrypt the cipher text once it
reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid-transit
to try and read the message not having
the secret key renders everyone helpless
looking to snoop in the symmetric key
algorithms like the data encryption
standard have been in use since the
1970s
while the popular ones like the ees have
become the industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used
you can understand why it's of paramount
importance to keep its secret on all
locations
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption
is it becomes a single point of failure
anyone who gets their hand on it can
read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and encryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages
to either the sender or the receiver
using the same key to encrypt the
message
upon receiving the message and
decrypting it with the key it is
impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography
since a big part of the data's integrity
is riding on the promise
that the users can keep the key secret
this terminology contrasts with
asymmetry key cryptography
which is called public key cryptography
because it has two different keys at
play
one of which is public
provided we managed to keep the key
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information
in symmetric key cryptography there are
broadly two categories of ciphers that
we can employ
let us have a look stream ciphers are
the algorithms that
encode basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it's
relies on a single bit or byte to do the
encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format
in stream ciphers each binary digit is
encrypted one after the other
the most popular ones are the rc4 salsa
and panama the binary data is passed
through an encryption key which is a
randomly generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
ciphertext that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of
man-in-the-middle attacks
the binary data can be passed through an
algorithmic function
it can have either x or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bit stream generator
and it acts as a supplement in the
algorithmic function
the output is in binary form which is
then converted into the decimal or
hexadecimal format to give our final
ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size
the size of these blocks depend on the
exact cipher being used
a 128 bit block cipher will break the
plain text into blocks of 128 bit each
and encrypt those blocks instead of a
single digit
once these blocks are encrypted
individually they are chained together
to form a final cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process
once the conversion is complete the
blocks are passed through the encryption
algorithm
along with the encryption key this would
provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get a ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like aes
des and 3des are all block cipher
methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things symmetrical
cryptography excels at
while falling short in some other
symmetric key cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography
there is only one key in play unlike
asymmetric encryption
and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption
and decryption similarly the performance
of symmetric encryption is
much more efficient under similar
computational limitations
fewer calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms
since they are much quicker handling
large amounts of data is simple and
easy to use in servers and data forms
this helps in better latency during data
recall
and fewer mixed packets thanks to its
simple single key structure
symmetric key cryptography algorithms
are much easier to set up a
communication channel with
and offer a much more straightforward
maintenance duties
once the secret key is transmitted to
both the sender and receiver without any
prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday communications becomes easy
and secure if the algorithm is applied
as per the documentation
symmetric algorithms are very robust and
can encrypt vast amounts of data with
very less overhead
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any questions
feel free to ask us in the comments
section subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this
and thanks for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here